foreign
[Music]
did you break your leg on it's the easy
one where I I'm running and I jump from
one building to the next yes I'm wearing
two wires they're basically just safety
wires because I go to Full Tilt I'm
sprinting as hard as I can we're
supposed to have a violent hit against
that wall and I'm supposed to grab the
top of the building because we always
knew it was going to be heavy impact in
that wall that was the shot and I was
just going to touch my right foot just
touch it just to slow down a little bit
so that I could grab the side and then
do it so I put my foot there and I just
left it there just I mean that look that
much too long I didn't want to do it
again I do I knew instantly it was
broken and I looked down I'm just in
character but going after I yield cut he
immediately took all of his weight off
the leg he powered through the shot
because he knew his ankle was broken and
he knew we were never coming back he was
told immediately afterwards by doctors
they said you won't be able to use it or
put weight in it properly until like six
months from now and you may never run
again six weeks later he was running
again